for 24 years of my adult life I weighed
well over 200 lb I say by choice because
you see I have never accidentally eaten
anything and when I choose to eat too
much today I have chosen to weigh too
much tomorrow you can choose to set
goals and realize your potential or you
can choose not to set them now if you
choose not to set them you got to
understand that the consequence Es are
not going to be good down the road Zig
Ziggler was one of the world's most
popular motivational speakers Ziggler
was one of 12 children raised by a
widowed mother during the Great
Depression he wrote over 25 books
including see you at the top and
inspired millions of people around the
world in his exclusive training Ziggler
shares with us practical insights on
goal setting the secrets to unlocking
the full potential of visualization and
confronts the realities of difficulties
and failure special thanks to the
Ziggler family for partnering with us to
release this exclusive content on our
YouTube channel
enjoy hello I'm Zig Ziggler and I'm
really excited that we're able to spend
this time together in a few minutes this
empty studio will be filled with
hundreds of people who just like you
believe that to get ahead in life you
got to have goals during this program
we'll look at why goals are important
how to set them and how to achieve them
the hour you spend with this tape may be
the most important time you'll ever
spend in your life now join me and our
studio audience as we take those first
steps towards a happier and more
productive life do this and I'll see you
at the
[Music]
[Applause]
top
[Music]
wow what enthusiasm my goodness alive
read something the other day you're
going to be enormously intrigued with
read where every third person was either
remark ably
handsome are
amazingly beautiful now what I'd like to
get you to do is look directly at the
person on your left no
left now look directly at the person on
your
right and if it ain't either one of
[Applause]
them well I all get I ought to get us
off to a good start
here just as a matter of curiosity how
many of you have ever either heard me
speak before or else this is your first
time can I see your hands
okay hey we're with it here tonight
that's great the name Howard Hill will
probably ring a bell in the minds of
some of you but not all of you Howard
Hill was a good Alabama boy he was an
Archer many people said he was the
greatest of all time he entered 287
archery tournaments he plays first
287 times as a youngster I've seen news
reels of Howard Hill I've seen him where
they were filing him killing a cape
buffalo the toughest of all game animals
to bring down with a bow and arrow he
killed a bull elephant he killed a large
shark under about 15 ft of water as a
youngster I've seen news reels where
from 50 ft he would shoot at a bullseye
and split it precisely in the Center and
then he would take his second arrow and
with the second Arrow he would split the
first one an amazing demonstration of
skill now I have never shot the boy in
Era professionally but I am an
instructor par Excellence I I think
that's French which means I'm really
good but but I'm not absolutely certain
of that as a matter of fact I am so good
as an instructor of archery that I could
spend 20 minutes with any man or woman
in this audience this evening and
provided your eyesight is normal and
your health is good at the end of 20
minutes I would have you hitting the
bullseye more consistently than Howard
Hill could have hit it the best day of
his life provided we had of course first
blindfolded Howard
Hill and then turn him around a couple
of times so he would have no idea in
which direction he was facing and you
kind of Snicker you say well ugly that's
the silliest thing I've ever heard why
of course we could shoot better than him
because how in the world could a man hit
a Target he could not even see that's a
pretty good question here's one even
better how can you hit a Target you
don't even
have the question my friends is do you
have your targets have you clearly
identified what it is that you want in
life have you set a date as to when you
expect to get it have you identified the
obstacles you must overcome in order to
get there have you identified the people
the groups organizations you need to
work with in order to get there have you
spelled out what it is you need to know
to reach your objective have you
developed a plan of action and have you
written it down as to what's in it for
me why do you want to reach the goal in
the first place you see the problem with
most people is that what we we call a
Wandering generality in life but the
truth is you can never achieve greatness
unless you become a meaningful specific
you see the basic problem is most people
when they're working on their job they
get to thinking you know I really ought
to be spending time at home with my
family and then when they at home with
the family get to thinking you really
ought to be out there working for my
family and so when they're out there
working for the family their mind is
back home and when they're back home
their mind is back out there in the
field and then they tell everybody well
I don't ever have time to do anything no
wonder you're always
traveling you see the basic problem is
not lack of time it is lack of
direction we all have exactly the same
amount of time whether we're a
millionaire or a poper all of us have 24
hours every single day the truth is
ladies and gentlemen we must have goals
if we're going to do anything goals do a
lot of things for example they enable
you to chase the blue lose away I've
never known anybody who was truly
depressed who had specific and long
range goals and what goals do is they
create activity and you see activity as
you work towards reaching them creates
the very excitement which you need in
order to accomplish or reach your
objectives the psychologist put it this
way logic will not change an emotion but
action will and as you get busy working
towards these dreams of yours and yes
you absolutely must have your dreams
ladies and gentlemen and what we're
going to do is look at the ways you
build a foundation underneath those
dreams several years ago they did an
experiment with a number of college
students and in this particular
experiment they let them go to sleep and
they hook these brain machines up to
them with these brain machines they
could determined precisely within a
matter of seconds when the student went
to sleep then they could tell when that
student started to dream and as the
student would start to dream they would
awaken him or her and then they'd let
him go back to sleep and that is no
problem but when they started to dream
they would awaken them again and with
those brain wave machines they can tell
exactly when they start to dream at the
end of one night of this kind of
treatment many of the students were
nervous and fidgety at the end of two
nights of this kind of treatment where
they had a reasonable amount of sleep
but no dreaming they became very
irritable and very short and very cross
at the end of just three nights of a
reasonable amount of sleep but no
dreaming they could tell that some of
them were headed for some psychological
difficulties and so what they did was
they aborted the experiment now about 24
hours later most of the students were
back to normal within a week all of them
had returned 100% but the experiment
proves something very conclusively and
that's this when you're asleep ladies
and gentlemen you need your dreams I'm
here to tell you that when you're wide
awake you also need your dreams you must
have your goals you'll never make it as
a Wandering generality you must become a
meaningful specific if you're going to
work tomorrow because that's what you
did yesterday you're not going to be as
good tomorrow as you were yesterday
because now you're two days older and no
closer to the goal which you do not have
you can't make it as a Wandering
generality most people understand you
got to become a meaningful specific it
reminds me of an experiment done some
little while ago by Jean Henry fabre the
great French naturalist he took a number
of processionary caterpillars so named
because they follow each other in a
procession and he lined them around a
flower pot until they formed a
NeverEnding Circle and they started
going round and round 24 4 hours that
first day and then there went the next
day and the next and by the about the
third or the fourth day he put some pine
needles into the center of that flower
pot that's the food of the processionary
caterpillar they kept going round and
round seven full days and seven full
nights they went round and round until
they literally dropped dead from
starvation and exhaustion with an
abundance of food less than 6 in away
they had starved to death because they
confused us used activity with
accomplishment you've got some friends
that are in the same shape they're busy
busy buy all the time they're going
going going going and they're here and
they're there and they're somewhere else
but they never really accomplish
anything because they don't have those
specific clearly identifiable objectives
you got to have those goals now that you
know why it's important to have goals
take the next few minutes to prepare a
drink Dream sheet write down everything
you've ever wanted to do or be or have
now don't be judgmental let your mind
run free here's a guide to help organize
this dream sheet as you write down one
idea it will trigger others no matter
how far-fetched or seemingly unrealistic
be sure to write down everything begin
with travel and vacations where you want
to go and how you going to get there
your automobile that kind the color all
of the options the house the the size of
it the style and all of the extras the
money savings Investments your career
the salary the increase the raises and
all the benefits which go with it your
promotions uh the children and your
family the education activities the
shared time friendship the respect the
helping of others your health your your
body weight the exercise your religion
your church involvement your religious
study and your mind education reading
Recall now if other things come to mind
you add them to your list take your time
to complete this list and when you're
finished set it aside for 24 to 48 hours
at that point get out your dream sheet
again and after each item write why now
this is crucial if you cannot clearly
articulate in one sentence why you want
to be do or have what you included on
your list it is not something you're
serious about so take it off we'll get
back to this later yet the truth of the
matter is
97% of the people in our great land
never really set their goals in the
proper light in the way that you're
going to be taught during the course of
this program
97% and one of the major reasons is
because of a little thing called fear
now you spell fear obviously f e a and
that really is an acostic for false
evidence appearing
real but if it appears real ladies and
gentlemen it's real for example I could
take this
handkerchief and my finger and rob the
bank in your town and probability all
I'd have to do is put the hang of over
my face put my finger in my pocket and
walk up to the toer and of my meanest
voice say give me your money and chances
are superb that they would give me the
money the evidence would be false but it
would appear real and because of that
they would give me the money a young
Cuban hijacked an airplane to Cuba with
a bar of soap he took it to the captain
of the aircraft and he said uh let's go
to Cuba I've got a bomb in here though
the evidence was false it appeared real
and they went to Cuba you see the truth
of the matter is a lot of people collect
a great deal of false evidence and the
net result is they never set the goals
now let me assure you there's a certain
amount of danger in setting goals for
example next Monday morning I get on an
aircraft in Dallas Texas going into
Atlanta Georgia at 8:45 now I've got
sense enough to know that when I get on
that airplane there's a certain amount
of danger when I get aboard that
aircraft because some airplanes are
coming down faster than they go up and
I'll tell you when those airplanes come
down faster than they go up there's
danger for me but there's more danger
for the airplane you see when an
airplane comes down faster than it goes
up you just about can't hardly trade
those dudes in at any price I mean their
market value is gone see there's danger
for the airplane but there's more danger
for the airplane if it stays on the
ground did you realize that according to
the engineers an airplane will wear out
faster sitting on the ground than it
will wear out flying in the heavens
it'll rust out on the ground it'll wear
out in the heavens not nearly as fast in
the air as it'll rust out on the ground
besides airplanes are built to
fly you get on a ship there's danger it
might sink but there's more danger for
the ship if it stays at anchor in the
harbor experts tell me that it will
collect Barnacles and become unseaworthy
faster in the harbor than it will if it
sails the high seas and besides that's
what ships are built for now there's a
certain amount of danger in setting your
goals because you see you might not
reach those goals but folks there's
danger if you don't set the go you see
man and nature are
180° apart we use up Nature's Natural
Resources by using them up but we use up
man's Natural Resources by not using
them at all Oliver wend Holmes expressed
it very eloquently when he said the
tragedy in America is truly that we
waste our natural resources but one of
infinitely greater tragedy is the fact
that we waste our Human Resources by not
using
what we've got the average person goes
to their grave with their music still in
them what a shame you got to have goals
ladies and gentlemen I want to talk a
little bit about goals on the line of
how do you lose 37 pounds and write a
book I'm just going to kind of give you
that as an example for 24 years of my
adult life by choice I weighed well over
200 lb I say by choice because you see I
have never accidentally eaten
anything I mean it's always been
deliberate and when I choose to eat too
much today I have chosen to weigh too
much tomorrow you can choose to set
goals and realize your potential or you
can choose not to set them now if you
choose not to set them you got to
understand that the consequences are not
going to be good down the road for 24
years I was going to lose that weight as
a matter of fact in 24 years I lost
several thousand pounds of weight how
many of you already know exactly what
I'm talking about but it wasn't until I
wrote it down put a date on it listed
the obstacles I had to overcome
identified the people the groups
organizations I needed to work with
spelled out a plan of action set that
time limit in there and identified all
of the benefits to me it was only when I
did that that the goal became a reality
and I lost the weight for 10 or 15 years
I was going to write a book you know
anybody who's going to do just a whole
lot of things folks I was going to write
a book but it wasn't until I got busy
writing the book and writing the plans
first before the book ever materialized
Yale University 1953 did a study of
their graduating seniors they discovered
that only 3% of them had taken all seven
of the steps you need to take in setting
your goals another 10% had taken part of
the steps but the majority 87% Beyond
graduating from college and becoming a
professor or a preacher or a doctor or
whatever very few of the other 87% had
taken any of the steps in setting those
goals now 19
1973 20 years later they did another
study of these graduating seniors and in
the area which you can measure which is
in your career and in your finances the
3% who had taken all seven steps that is
they had written down clearly identified
exactly what they wanted they had put
the date on when they expected to get
there they had identified the obstacles
they had to overcome they had spelled
out the people the groups organizations
they had to work with that identified
what they needed to know they had
developed a plan of action and they had
written it down why do I want to get
there these 3% had accomplished more
than the
97% combined who had not set those go
goals now if it sound like I'm trying to
sell you on having goals how many of you
are getting close already how many of
you are being becoming convinced right
quick like that you need to have those
goals there's no question about it the
immortal JC Penny many many years ago
said give me a stock clerk work with a
goal and I'll give you a man who will
make history but give me a man without a
goal and I'll give you a stock clerk now
the interesting thing is Golds do not
care who has them let me give you a
classic example of the way they work in
1950 a war torn devastated Japan a
nation which had lost an incredibly high
percentage of its young men their cities
were in Ruins said bombed out but in
1950 they got together they meaning
industry and government got together and
set a goal the goal was we're going to
be the number one nation in the world
during the 1950s in the production of
textiles in
1959 ladies and gentlemen they
accomplished that objective in 1960 they
set another goal we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of Steel now when you
understand there's no iron or in Japan
of any significance there's no C of any
significance there we're going to be the
number one nation in the world in the
production of Steel it seemed like an
absurd goal and yet they reached their
objectives they had taken all of the
steps in 1970 the Japanese set another
goal they said during the 70s we'll be
the number one nation in the world in
the production of automobiles they
missed it folks one year it took them
until 1980 in 1980 they set another goal
and this time their goal was we're going
to be the number one nation in the world
in the production of computers and
electronics and they're working very
very hard to reach their goals yes
indeed ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely must have those goals you got
to write them down you got to put a date
on it you got to identify those
obstacles you've got to identify the
people the groups you need to work with
you got to find out what it is you need
to know you got to develop a plan of
action and you got to write it down
what's in it for me now that's a formula
that I have just given you pure and
simple now if I were to ask you what 3 *
3 was there isn't a person here who
could not instantly answer it but if I
were to ask you what is
5,128 *
2,165 odds are enormous that very few of
you could pop out the answer that
quickly but if I were to say to you get
your pencil and paper out figure it out
then all of you could figure it out why
you know the formula now you see if you
know the formula it really doesn't make
any difference ladies and gentlemen what
the goal really is when I started to
write the book I took precisely the same
steps that I'm talking about I wrote
down the objective I wrote down the time
I completed or expected to complete the
book identified the obstacles there and
yes I know this is repetitious it's the
mother of learning I wrote out and
identified the people the groups
organizations I needed to work with with
I devised a plan of action to do it I
spelled out what I needed to know and I
wrote it all down what's in it for me I
think most of us would like to be part
of that successful group of people with
goals but few of us take the time to sit
down and write out our plan for Life the
truth is most of us just don't know how
to go about doing it so here are seven
steps to help you start setting goals
first you've got to identify the goal
next you need to set a deadline for
achievement number three you need to
list the obstacles to overcome number
four you need to identify the people and
groups to work with number five you need
to list the skills and the knowledge
required to reach your goal number six
you need to develop a plan of action and
number seven you need to list the
benefits what's in it for me these are
the seven steps you must take to set
your goals the truth of the matter is
you see there are seven types of goals
but the formula works exactly the same
whether it's a social goal a mental goal
a physical goal doesn't make a
difference what kind of goal is let me
kind of alert you and give you a simple
example of why we need to be alerted to
why we need some of our goals for
example is there anybody here who has a
racehorse worth in excess of a million
dollars can I see your hands okay now if
you did have a thorough breed horse
worth in excess of a million dollars
would you keep him up half the night
letting him drink coffee and booze and
smoke cigarettes and eat junk
food now chances are you'd say zgla
that's crazy of course now how about a
$10 dog would you treat him that
way $5
cat what about a billion dollar body see
we need goals identified to take care of
our physical body we need family goals
we need career goals we need spiritual
goals and yes we also ladies and
gentlemen need financial
goals hey there it's Mark Tim with the
Ziggler family and I sure hope you're
enjoying the video from my mentor the
legendary Zig Ziggler because you're
part of evans's audience we want to give
you a special bonus it's a cool little
book called the little book of big
quotes packed with awesome content this
book is free just for you check out the
description below and it's yours all
righty let's get you back to Z before
going any further it's time to take a
personal inventory kind of a checkup
from the neck up to see how you're
performing in various areas of your life
as each area appears on the screen
evaluate yourself on a scale of 1 to
five five being excellent begin with a
physical area of your life life rate
yourself on appearance medical checkups
exercise programs weight control and
nutrition the next area is the family
your listening habits your forgiving
attitude of being a good role model time
together supportive of others respectful
and loving Financial earnings your
savings and Investments budget adequate
Insurance charge accounts social your
sense of humor your listening habits
your self-confidence your manners and
caring the spiritual the inner peace the
sense of purpose prayer religious study
belief in God mental imagination
attitude continuing education reading
and curiosity career job satisfaction
Effectiveness job training understanding
the job the purpose and your
competence now review your performance
in all seven areas and determine which
areas need Improvement we will use this
evaluation later in the program to help
you set your goals now goals have
certain characteristics for example we
need some big goals and some multiple
goals we need more than one goal if you
just have one goal you'll end up being a
warped individual now if you only have
one goal chances are good you're going
to reach it if you work at it as we've
been talking about uh but you don't want
to be warped you need the balance that
we're talking about I'd set the goal of
losing the 37 pounds now that is a big
goal you need big goals because big
goals force you to reach in and utilize
the potential which is there I love the
story of Old Gentleman Jim Corbett the
former heavyweight box and champion of
the world Corby was out doing his road
work one morning and he saw our
fisherman who was just having a field
day I mean he was pulling in the big
ones and he was pulling in the little
ones and carbin noticed that as he was
running past the fisherman was putting
the little fish in his creel and he was
throwing the big ones back in he
couldn't resist it he walked over to him
ran over to him and said mister he said
I've seen a lot of fisherman in my
lifetime but I believe you're the first
one I've ever seen who threw the big
fish back and who kept the little ones
now why in the world would you do a
thing like that and the fisherman sadly
shook his head and he said man I I hate
to do it but he said I don't really have
any choice I have to throw the big ones
back because you see all I've got just
this little old bitty frying
pan now before you laugh too broad let
me point out he's talking to you and
about you and he's talking about me so
many times we got the Big Goal the big
idea the big dream something that would
make a big difference not only in our
lives but other lives and no sooner do
we get this big old and say oh no Lord
don't give me such a big one all I got
just this little old bitty frying pan
give me a little one just a little one
don't make me stret besides you know if
the goal was any good if the idea was
any good somebody else would already
have thought about it just give me a
little one folks you got to have some
big goals in life because it's the big
goals which really make you reach in and
uh res and use the resources which are
at your disposal
and the resources you have are awesome
Emerson was absolutely right when he
said what lies behind us and what lies
in front of us pales in significance
when compared to what lies within us
you've got within you the capacity to
reach some of those big goals and you
need to follow the steps we're talking
about because that makes them sensible
and sound and logical but we need some
dreams we need some big goals one of my
goals was to lose 37 lbs because I was
sick and tired of being sick and tired
in a nutshell and one of the toughest
things I've ever done in my life was to
discipline myself to get on that
exercise program requiring the jogging
and requiring the dieting up until then
you see my idea of exercise had been
simply to fill the tub take a bath pull
the plug and fight the current I mean
you know that was
it and anyway you cut it folks that
really is not much of an exercise
program and I finally got on it and I
went to work to lose that weight now it
took 10 months that was a big goal it
was a goal which made a definite
difference in my life writing the book
was a big goal it made a different a
definite difference in my life now you
got to have some long range gos as well
ladies and gentlemen now I don't want to
be negative matter of fact I'll be like
the little boy who came home from school
one day and said Dad I'm afraid I flun
the arithmetic test his dad said son
that's negative be positive he said Dad
I'm positive I flun the arithmetic
test now I'm absolutely positive folks
that you're going to have some
difficulties in your life in front of
you ladies and gentlemen there is
trouble some friends of yours are going
to disappoint you your employer or
employees are going to disappoint you
there's going to be some setbacks and
reversals that you absolutely cannot
understand there're going to be things
happen in your future that will
frustrate you flabbergast you amaze you
disgust you and everything else and
that's the reason you've got to have
long range goals you see if you've got
those specific long range goals ladies
and gentlemen and then when things don't
go exactly your way you will treat the
setbacks as a pebble on the beach if you
don't have those goals you'll treat it
as if it were the whole ocean front you
got got to have long range goals and the
reason you need long range goals is
because the long range goals help you to
deal with and overcome those short range
failures the rule is very simple you go
as far as you can see and then when you
get there you'll always be able to see
further I set my goal to lose 37 pounds
in 10 months that was my objective and
as I looked at it 37 lbs in 10 months I
knew and I knew in my own mind that I
could reach that goal of losing 37 PBS
in the 10 months but we got to break
things down like when I get aboard that
aircraft in Dallas going into Atlanta
you see for the first 20 minutes we'll
be headed straight towards Atlanta but
after 20 minutes we'll no longer be
going to Atlanta don't know where we'll
be going but he won't be Atlanta Georgia
because the direction of the wind will
change the velocity will change the
gravitation pull of the Earth the Sun
the moon and the stars will all blow
that airplane off the course and so the
captain of the aircraft will turn the
aircraft around fly back to Dallas land
and start
over just saying if you're paying
attention how many of you how many of
you know perfectly good and well he's
not going to do that he's going to make
a different heading is he not he's going
to change the course you see when you
have those long range goals a lot of
thing times things happen to you well
you don't abandon the gold as my younger
brother judge Ziggler says you don't
change your decision to go you simply
change your direction in order to get
there see we can't always predict what's
going to be out there when I set the
goal of losing the 37 lbs in 10 months I
broke it into 10 parts 10 months I was
going to do it that's 3 and 710 pounds
per month now folks I knew I could lose
3 and 710 pounds a month you see that's
less than pound a week I knew and I knew
that I knew that I could lose 3 and 710
pound a month as a matter of fact I was
so certain that I could but I didn't
even bother to get started the first 28
days how many have you know exactly what
I'm talking about I mean listen man the
contest is 6 months why get all
exercised about it the first week or but
Mom school just started we've got nine
more months why should I knuckle down
and study now oh look I've got all week
to get the correspondence out boss man
or boss lady why should I hustled so
hard today but you know Time Marches on
28 days and then I realized what was
happening I was raised in the little
town of yzu City Mississippi now I know
that a lot of folks go around the
country trying to impress people by
claiming to be from yazu City uh but I
really am now when I was a boy during
the Depression and we live next door to
some rich folks I knew they were Rich
for two reasons number one they had a
cook number two the cook had something
to cook and during the Depression that
was a sure sign of wealth I was over
there for lunch one day as I tried to be
every day and I don't misunderstand that
even though there was a depression on we
certainly had plenty to eat at my house
I know we had plenty because if I ever
pass my place for seconds they'd always
tell me no you've had plenty so I know
we had plenty now the cook brought the
biscuits out and this is not an
exaggeration those biscuits were not as
thick as my wrist was and I looked at
her for a moment I said M what in the
world happened to your biscuits she
rared back gave a big old tummy life and
said well I'll tell you about those
biscuits she said they squatted to
rise but she said they just got cooked
in the
squat you know anybody that's get cooked
in the squat you know anybody who's
going to do something just as soon as
are there half a m to do such and such
thing you ever have anybody say well you
know wait kids get out of school and
then I'll really get involved in this
project we got so many things going on
right now wait out of school wait till
summer time comes and then I'll really
get busy the kids get out of school you
know what they say then well you know I
didn't realize but I got to take the
kids somewhere every day I had more time
when they were in school waiting to get
back in school and then I really get
busy kids get back in school you know
what they say then well you know for the
first time in 19 years dear old Central
High finally got a winning football team
and you got to support the kids that way
like the football season's over then
I'll really get busy football season
then you know what they say then well
here it is Thanksgiving and Christmas
and New Year's and people don't want to
be bother with this sort of thing this
time of year wait after the first of the
year man then I'll really get busy after
the first of the year you know what they
say well it's the weather did did you
ever see weather like this in Chicago or
San Francisco or Dallas or wherever wait
till the weather settles down and then
I'll really get busy oh I know what
you're thinking you're thinking I've
lost interest in it but that's not the
way I do they did just let me tell you
the way I do things now here's the way I
am s this is just the way I do
[Music]
[Applause]
it see the way I do things is I get
everything organized I get it lined up I
have everything in just such and such
order and then man once I get it all put
together that's when I really get after
I mean that's just the way I've always
been that way do things that way I know
some of these other folks are head up
right now but you just wait I'll catch
them but this weather it is just so
horrible wait till it clears up and the
weather clears up you know what they say
then well here it is it's Easter time
and Easter time you know that's a family
time and we always spend a lot of time
together and you said so yourself the
family is extremely important to you you
do the work for the family and if you
can't spend some time with them you
might as well not do all of the work I
mean wait after Easter's over then I'll
really get busy and then after this you
know what they say at long last we've
got some beautiful weather and I have it
hit a go ball or wet a hook and I don't
know when man I got to have some RNR I
got to have some rest and relaxation and
you know you said if you can't work all
the time I mean an individual need some
time with them say wait till I relax a
little bit and man then I'll really get
after it and finally they get after a
little bit you know or when they have
the fun and relaxation then they say
well it's almost time for the kids to
get out of
school and that's where we came in as we
say Down Home Folks you can put this in
your pipe and smoke it because it's the
truth the people who wait for a Matilda
to move out or John to get on the day
shift or the new models to come out or
the new mayor to come in or for the new
advertising campaign to get started the
people who wait on the new senator in
Washington or until inflation slows or
the rate of interest come down the
people who wait for changes to take
place out there before they do the
changing in here are flat going to end
up getting cooked in the squat the rule
is simple you do it now you do it now
when I analyzed what I had to do when I
wrote it down and understood my
objective that all I had to do was lose
one and 29 1 and 29 hundreds oun per day
then 10 months later to the inch to the
Ounce and to the day I had lost the
weight the truth of the matter is in
writing the book it's a 384 page book
it's entitled see you at the top we've
sold in excess of a, 500,000 copies I
wrote 1. 2600 Pages a day for 10 months
you see to reach your goals ladies and
gentlemen it does not involve Monumental
undertakings every day of your life but
what it does involve is a lot of
commitment a lot of decision and working
on it in a Relentless steady committed
basis you got to do something every
every day when I broke it down into that
specific thing you see Golds you got to
be specific you can't make it as a
Wandering generality you absolutely must
become a meaningful specific you can
take the hottest day of the world has
ever seen take the most powerful
magnifying glass you can buy in any
store and hold that magnifying glass
over a pile of newspaper clippings on
that hottest day and you'll never start
a
fire to keep the glass moving but the
moment you hold that glass still harness
the power of the sun multiply it through
the glass and boom you got to fire you
got to have specific goals my goal was
specific write the book by July 4th lose
the weight at the same time to the inch
to the Ounce and to the day it all came
to pass you've got to have those
specific goals during this program we've
asked you to prepare a dream sheet and a
self- evaluation sheet look at your
self- evaluation a sheet and determine
which areas need Improvement set some
specific goals for these areas now take
your dream sheet and itemize only those
things which you truly want to achieve
combine these items with those from the
self evaluation sheet and you will have
a comprehensive list of your major goals
from this new list select at least two
goals you will work on every day it will
be easier to select the goals if you
remember that for each goal you must
answer yes to these five questions
number one is it really my goal number
two is it morally right and fair number
three are my short range goals
consistent with my long range goals
number four can I commit myself
emotionally to complete the project and
number five can I visualize myself
reaching this goal for each goal you
plan to work on daily set a deadline for
achievement list the obstacles you need
to overcome identify the people in
groups you need to work with list the
necessary skills and knowledge develop a
plan of action and list the benefits you
will receive then periodically
re-evaluate each of your goals when one
goal is reached replace it immediately
with another your emphasis on certain
goals may change so it is critical to
review your goals list regularly now the
question often comes with all of us if
we want to reach our goals how do you go
about it do you share your goals with
other people that possibly is the most
often asked question of all to me how
and who do you share your goals with and
the rule is basically fairly simple if
it's a give up goal you share it with
everybody if it's a go up goal you share
it only with those people whom you love
and trust and whom you know are going to
be supportive of you now for example a
give up goal if I'm going to give up
eating too much or drinking too much if
I'm going to give up smoking if I'm
going to give up cussing if I'm going to
give up being mean and nasty and Ary any
of the go give up gos like that I want
to share it with other people because
others are supportive and they will
encourage you in that but but for
example if you're a
salesperson and your goal is to be the
number one sales lady in the
organization or the number one salesman
in the organization and you go to
another one of the sales ladies and say
hey I'm going to be number one sales
lady in this whole organization this
whole year and that lady's objective was
to do the same thing do you think she's
going to say to you yeah you can sure do
it when all the time she's wanting to do
it uh-uh but if you go home and tell
your husband or your wife yes indeed I'm
going to be number one this year you'll
get the encouragement and the support
there which is so extremely important
yes you really have to have that
understanding of goals if they give up
goals share them with everybody if they
go up goals share them only with the
people whom you know will give you the
support want to reach your goals you got
to make a commitment now one of the
basic problems in life is so many people
do not make commitments when I was
losing that weight one of the toughest
things I've ever done in my life was
continue to deny myself the food which I
so dearly love especially the sweets and
it was really tough to get involved in
all of that jogging but I had made a
commitment and because the commitment
was made I really decided I was going to
stay with it I had another commitment
when I wrote the book one of the first
things I put in there was that I weighed
165 lbs and that I had a 34in waistline
I had it typ set now at the time I put
that in there I weigh 202 lbs and had a
41 in waistline now the reason that's
imported is very simply this I could not
get a publisher to publish the book
initially for me later is no trouble but
initially I could not I had to publish
the book myself and in that I decided to
order 25,000 copies a friend said if you
sell 25,000 copies you got yourself a
best seller so I ordered 25,000 copies
of the book now let me tell you
something about books the first copy
cost you more than the next 24
$4,999 and those
24,999 ain't cheap I'm talking about a
whole bunch of money now I made a
financial commitment to buy those books
I also had written in there that I
weighed 165 pounds now let me tell you
something about human nature if I tell
you one lie and you catch me in it from
here on in everything I say you're going
to put a question mark after it if you
tell me a lie and I catch in it from
here on in everything you say to me I'm
going to put a question Mark in it in my
book I wrote I weighed 165 lbs I had
25,000 copies of the book now you can
imagine what would happen if I had not
lost the weight now I got a warehouse
full of books s away 165 and I come
waddling out at 202 and your next
question would be I wonder what else he
lied to me about friends I made a
commitment there is no question about it
you got to make a commitment and you got
to understand something which is
extremely important and that is that
your vocabulary makes a great deal of
difference in your success in life I got
to apologize for those people who've
heard me do this but for years I went
around the country and with a strained
expression on my face and pain in my
voice I'd say you got to
pain the price sound like a dying calf
in a
snowstorm and what a bunch of baloney
that was I I'll never forget nine months
of hating J Jing and hating joggers how
many of you hate joggers can I see
you're hand okay for nine months I
really hated those joggers you know
every time I saw one he's jumping up and
down and saying man it makes you feel so
good it gives you so much energy and
there I was hating and hurting every
step I was taking and fussing about it
too and then that day in Portland Oregon
never forget it if I live to be 150
beautiful spring day temperature about
78° it was high noon I was running on
Portland State University campus had a
seminar at 4:00 this was high noon and
as I was running out there that day I
noticed a lot of this students were
laying on blankets some were reading
some were studying some recording some
were snoozing and here comes old Ziggler
running by sweat running down my back
sweat running down my legs and all of a
sudden it hit me that for the first time
I was really enjoying running I was
having a ball and that day I changed my
vocabulary the the truth is folks you
don't pay the price for good health you
enjoy the benefits of good health you
don't pay the price for setting goals
you pay the price for not setting those
goals you enjoy the benefits of reaching
those goals you don't pay the price for
a good marriage you pay the price for a
poor one you enjoy the benefits of the
good one you you don't pay the price for
good health you pay the price for poor
health you enjoy the benefits of good
health yes your vocabulary really does
make a great deal of difference as to
whether or not you reach your goals or
not we definitely need to keep it
positive because you see the mind takes
whatever picture you paint in it and
goes to work to complete that picture I
want to emphasize that what you get by
reaching your goal is not nearly as
important as what you become by reaching
them the attitudes Knowledge and Skills
and habits developed by people with
goals are of infinite value in the
tomorrow of their lives with goals you
can more fully realize your maximum
potential because goals enable you to
know be do and have more use your mind
and talents fully have more purpose and
direction in life make better decisions
be more organized and effective do more
for yourself and others have greater
confidence and self-worth feel more
fulfilled be more enthusiastic and
motivated and yes accomplish some
uncommon projects want to reach your
goals you got to know how to train fleas
now just as a matter of curiosity how
many of you in this audience do not know
how to train fleas can I see your hands
please boy it looks like I got to you
just in
time and I know you heard the one about
the two fleas at the bottom of the hill
and one of them said well do we walk or
take a
dog well
anyhow you train fleas by putting them
in a jar and you put the top on the jar
and those fleas will jump up and they'll
hit that top over and over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over and you watch them jump for a
long period of time and they'll keep on
jumping and hitting and jumping and
hitting and you watch them and then all
of a sudden you'll notice that even
though they continue to jump they will
no longer be hitting the top literal
truth then you can take the top off and
they'll jump and jump and jump and jump
and jump and jump but they cannot I
repeat they cannot jump out and the
reason they cannot jump out is because
they've been conditioned to jump just so
high and once they've conditioned
themselves to jump just so high that's
all there is there ain't no more man is
precisely the the same way he starts out
in life to climb the mountain to write
the book to break the record to do
something with his life and along the
way he bumps his head he stubs his toe
and he becomes what I call a snop now a
snop and that is spelled SN i o p is a
person who is susceptible to the
negative influence of other people
classic example that everybody will
instantly recognize is the 4minute mile
for years and years and years athletes
the world over had tried to run a mile
in 4 minutes but because they were SN
Ops they could not do it the coach had
taken his watch out and said man there
ain't no way you can do it in 4 minutes
maybe 402 maybe 405 but not 4 minutes
the doctors said put the stethoscope on
the athletes heart instead of four
minute mile you got to be kidding man
nobody will ever do that your heart will
come right out of the body it is
impossible and nobody could run a
4minute mile until a fleet trainer named
Roger banister came along and ran a mile
in less than 4 minutes when banister ran
the mile in less than four minutes
athletes the world over started running
miles in less than four minutes land of
Australia did it less than 6 weeks later
I was in New Zealand last year and the
man over there Thompson I believe is his
name though please don't hold me to that
had just run his 100th four minute or
sub four minute mile a 37y old man ran a
mile in less than four minutes there
have been four or five races were eight
young men all broke the 4minute barrier
in the same race now what am I saying
with all this I'm saying that Roger
banister got something started and I'm
also going to tell you that Roger
banister understood more about gold
setting than just about anybody you will
ever know he didn't just train superbly
and go run a sub four minute mile yes he
trained extraordinarily hard but he
measured his stride he timed himself for
the hundred to the 220 the 440 he had
Pacers who paced him for the first
quarter the second quarter the third
quarter and the fourth quarter he did it
as scientifically and as carefully as
any gold setter I've ever seen in my
life yes Roger banister is a flea
trainer what's a flea trainer a fleet
trainer is a person who's driven from
within they're not influenced by the SN
Ops and the negative people in life a
fleet trainer is an individual who jumps
out of the jar a fleet trainer
understands that you can get everything
in life you want if you'll just help
enough other people get what they want
Fleet trainers don't tell others where
to get off flea trainers show them how
to get on flea trainers don't try to see
through other people flea trainers see
other people through want to reach your
goals ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely must become a fleet trainer
and you've got to build a winning
attitude we could talk talked three days
3 weeks 3 months about building winning
attitudes Harvard University did an
exhaustive study on it discovered that
85% of the reason that people get jobs
and get ahead in those jobs is because
they have the right mental attitude the
co report involving well over a thousand
corporate Executives these men and women
were asked the question how important do
you think your attitude is in
accomplishing your objective of becoming
corporate Executives
49% of these men and women said that
their attitudes were extremely
significant 46 and a 12% said they were
significant in other words 95 a half% of
these more than 1,000 Executives said
their attitudes were significant or
extremely significant to reach your
goals yes indeed you absolutely must
have the right mental attitude and
ladies and gentlemen let me say without
any hesitation at all if you're going to
reach your goals you got to get other
people involved you simply cannot reach
major objectives entirely on your own
you got to understand that the influence
other people have and the help they can
give you will play a major role in what
you do when I was a small boy down in yu
City Mississippi I never shall forget
there was an abandoned section of the
railroad track and as boys will do we
often went down there and one of our
little games was to see how far we could
walk on that railroad track without
falling off and we'd take a few steps
and we'd fall and we'd take a few steps
and we would fall had we only understood
that two of us could simply have gotten
parallel with each other reached across
the rails and held hands that we could
have literally gone indefinitely without
falling off when business when
management and
labor understand that they're on the
same side when husbands and wives and
children understand that they're on the
same side when employer and employee
understand that they both have the same
objectives when they begin to work
together that's when everybody really
benefits the most you look at the Super
Bowl teams every year and by and large
you're going to have the super B Team
the number one had major objectives that
was it incidentally did you realize that
they spend over 3,000 hours each team
preparing for that specific event did
you realize that the average American
spends infinitely more time planning a
vacation than they do planning their
lives did you realize that more people
spend more time planning the wedding
than they do the marriage you see we
need ladies and gentlemen we need those
specific objectives and we need to work
together on these things if we really
are going to work at our maximum and the
most people benefit the most you need to
work together it's a matter of curiosity
how many of you have ever seen a flock
of Canadian geese flying overhead can I
see your hands okay if you have you will
notice three things about those Canadian
Gees number one they always fly in a V
formation
number two if you will notice them one
leg of the V is always longer than the
other leg of the V and number three if
you follow them carefully enough and
long enough you'll notice there's a
considerable amount of confusion in the
flock now just as a matter of curiosity
how many of you have ever wondered why
one leg of the V is always longer than
the other one can you see your hands
please well let me explain expain that
the longer leg is longer because it has
more geese in
[Laughter]
it you know I don't know why but that
silly thing just really grabs me I can't
wait I can't wait to get to that
particular one okay now the reason
there's confusion in the flock is that
periodically they change the leadership
of the flock of geese now the reason
they fly in a V formation is because in
Wind Tunnel test they've discovered that
the flock of geese can fly 63% further
than the individual Goose could fly what
they do the lead goose in fighting the
head wind creates a partial vacuum off
either wing and those other geese are
flying in a partial vacuum he grows
tired very easily or more quickly than
the others and so they replace
leadership real often to give the leader
a rest but by working together they can
fly 63% further in reaching your
objectives yes indeed you really do need
to work with other people if you're
going to reach your goals ladies and
gentlemen you got to get in shape now I
want to emphasize something here which I
believe is enormously important in order
to reach all of our goals we need to get
in shape spiritually because that is a
very definite fact in our life we have
spiritual goals but we need spiritual
help a lot of times to reach all of the
other goals it requires study it
inquires prayer it it requires
involvement there we need to get in
shape physically ladies and gentlemen
because I don't care what your objective
is I can share this with you without any
reservation when I got in shape
physically I was able to do a lot more
things with my career because the energy
level increased rather dramatically I
have far more energy now than I had when
I was 25 years old they tell me the
psychologist do for example that when I
make a one-hour presentation that I burn
more raw energy than a laboring man does
in a 10hour day so when I do six and
eight hours a day or even three or four
hours in a day or even one hour in a day
I have burned some energy as you can
tell I speak at about 280 words a minute
with gust up to about 550 I mean you
know I burn some energy I move it on out
now you also need to understand that if
you're going to reach your goals you got
to become attentive to the details in
your life a lot of little things that
many people Overlook and you need to
become aware on a daily basis of what
you're doing towards those goals now I'm
not trying to get you to be as detail
oriented as the Executive Vice President
of our company I mean he proofreads the
zod's copies I I I don't think uh you
know that's what we're talking about but
it is the little things that make the
big difference you call a girl a kitten
for example and she'll love you call her
a cat you see you got a problem there
you you can say she's a vision you score
all kind of points call her a saint
you're in bad trouble it's one thing to
tell a young lady that she looks like
the first day of spring it's another
thing to tell her she looks like the
last day of a long hard winter I mean
there is a difference it's the little
things fellas if you look at your wife
and say you know honey when I look into
your eyes the wheels of time just stand
still that's beautiful that's portrait
that's motivating that's exciting but
can you imagine what would happen if you
were to look at her and say you know
honey you got a face said stop a clock I
mean it's the little things if if if
this watch of mine were 4 hours wrong I
wouldn't have any trouble with it I can
tell you answer if my watch is 4 hours
wrong but if it's 4 minutes wrong I'm in
trouble for example tomorrow morning I
catch a flight at 8:20 now my watch is 4
minutes wrong and I get there at
8:24 see what the problem is I I made a
deal with the airlines that you know if
I was not there when they got ready to
go that they were just to go ahead
without me and I found out last year
that they live up to their end of the
agreement found out also it's easier to
catch those dudes before they leave the
ground all of that to say it's the
little things that make a big difference
if you want to reach your goals ladies
and gentlemen not only must you be
detail oriented looking after the little
things but you also must literally be
able to see the reaching I had my
physical examination at the Cooper
Clinic Preparatory to losing the weight
and getting on the exercise program
one of the things I did over there and
this is kind of ugly but I had not read
ant lard at the time and I'll use it as
my excuse although I really knew better
you know Ann says you're not supposed to
steal Pages out of other folks magazines
there was a magazine at Dr Cooper's
office it was an old magazine now and
there was a picture in it advertising
jocky shorts now I don't know if you
folks read the jocky short ads or not
but if you don't read the jocky short
Edge the next time you see one you ought
to at least look at a picture uh you'll
find out in a hurry they don't put
jockey shorts on Fat Boys I mean they
just
don't at least they don't have a good
year now I took that picture of that
fell in those jockey shorts and I hung
it up in my bath room and I said now
there's my hero that's the way I'm going
to be that's the way I am going to look
well the next morning at 5:30 the
opportunity clock sounded off negative
people call them alarm clocks uh you
know the opportunity I mean if you you
can hear it that gives you an
opportunity to get up and go you know
what I mean opportunity clock sounded
off I rolled out of bed put on my fancy
running outfit I just got and hit the
front door and ran a block literally did
better the next day I ran a block and a
mailbox did better than that the next
day I ran a block in two mailboxes I'll
never forget what happened and finally
one day I ran a half a mile then a mile
then two miles and three then four then
five but every time I went in the
bathroom ladies and gentlemen I saw the
picture of that guy in the jockey shorts
that became my goal right there I
visualized myself as looking just like
that guy right there I'm going to look
like this man in the jockey shorts the
truth of the matter is we really do need
to have a clearly defined Target we need
to be able to literally see ourselves as
reaching that objective for many many
years before I ever
succeeded quote on the platform as a
speaker it was my dream to do exactly
that I cannot begin to tell you the tens
of thousands of speeches I made in my
mind in order to reach that particular
goal I visualized every speech
imaginable and the beautiful thing about
imagination you see is you can visualize
any kind of speech and any kind of
response you want in these speeches
which I made in my mind and boy do I
ever wish we could have recorded just
one of them you talking about speeches
you've heard about speakers having folks
rolling in the aisles I had them rolling
up and down the steps you heard you know
about Standing Ovation my average
standing ovation was 11 minutes in my
dreams I mean listen I never made a
mistake in the speech I had in my mind
the audience sit there with Incredible
Rapture and attention I mean as if they
could not believe that a mere mortal
could utter such incredible words of
wisdom I mean the beautiful thing about
the imagination is you see you can make
it absolutely just right you got to have
your dreams but let me tell you
something folks be careful about your
dreams be very careful because you see
when you dream those dreams when you
write them down when you put a date on
it when you list the obstacles which you
have to overcome in order to get there
when you identify the people the groups
and the organizations you need to work
with in order to get there when you
spell out what you've got to know in
order to reach your objective Liv when
you devise that plan of action that game
plan to get there and when you write it
down what's in it for me when you do all
of those things ladies and gentlemen and
follow some of these other steps that
we're talking about and are still
talking about you're going to be
reaching some of those objectives I can
honestly look you in the eye and say
that virtually every major objective
I've ever set in my life has been
reached and I honestly believe that the
rest of them will be reached when when
you follow the steps with firm
conviction when you've made your
commitments when you do all the things
we're talking about things are going to
happen in your life if you'll notice
I've not even hinted throughout this
entire presentation that it is easy
because it is not as a matter of fact
I'm absolutely convinced that life is
tough but the point is you got to be
tough on yourself and when you're tough
on yourself uh then life is going to be
infinitely easier on you I can tell you
it's fun I can tell you it's exciting I
can tell you it's rewarding and I can
tell you that when you follow all of the
steps we're talking about that all the
goals we've been talking about the
physical the mental the spiritual the
social the career goals the financial
goals they all come to pass you see the
interesting thing is as we look at our
goals there's no such thing as an
individual goal when I set the goal for
example of writing that book only that
one and 20 600 Pages a day little did I
realize that it would have such a
bearing on my social goals you'll be
amazed at the people that invite me to a
free dinner now since I wrote a book I
mean it affected my social life but you
know what it also affected my family
life because it had to do a lot of
research to put it together it improved
our relationship it improved my
spiritual life because again I had to do
some research there it definitely inove
improved my physical life because I tied
it in had a dram IC impact on my career
had an impact in every phase of my life
your goals are going to do the same
thing there's no such thing as an
isolated goal they're all tied in to so
many of your other goals in order to
reach your goals we need to be able to
visualize all of them many years ago in
the days of the sailing ship there was a
young sailor who was out at sea for the
first time and he was ordered a off to
trim the sails because a Squall was
coming up and as he started to climb up
he made the mistake of looking down and
the roll of the ship and the turbulence
of the sea combined to cause him to
become nauseated and he started to lose
his balance and fall an older sailor
underneath shouted up at the young man
look up son look up and the young sailor
looked up and immediately regained his
balance you see the message is very
clear when the Outlook isn't good try
the uplook it's always good and when
things don't look good look to make
absolutely certain that you're not
facing in the wrong direction as Helen
Keller so eloquently put it when you're
looking at the sun you won't see the
shadows and when you're looking towards
your objectives which you've set you
won't be seeing so many of the obstacles
as you reach towards those goals many
years ago as some of you know the Great
Houdini was in his Heyday some people
said that Houdini was the greatest
magician who ever lived he was also the
Master Locksmith he made the boast that
he could get out of any jail cell in the
world if you'd let him walk in that jail
cell with a street clothes on he would
be out in less than an hour a small town
in the British aisles built a new jail
they were tremendously proud of it they
didn't believe who in or anybody else
get out of their jail and so they
challenged him to come give it a try
there's a lot of publicity a lot of
money involved Houdini liked both of
those things so he accepted the
challenge there was the lot of the
publicity going in the drums were
beating the bugles were blaring and
Houdini strowed triumphantly into the
jail cell they closed the door behind
him Houdini took his coat off and
secreted in his belt was a 10-in piece
of Steel very tough very flexible very
durable and he went to work on on the
lock at the end of 30 minutes The
Confident even arrogant expression on
Houdini's face had disappeared at the
end of an hour he was absolutely bathed
in perspiration at the end of two hours
he actually collapsed and fell against
the
door which
opened because it had never been
locked anywhere except in Houdini's own
mind which me very simply that it was
locked more securely than if every
locksmith in Britain had put their best
locks on the door I got to tell you
folks there are a lot of people who can
stop you
temporarily but I'm also going to look
you right in ey and tell you that you
are the only one who can stop you on a
permanent basis and I've got an idea as
you digest what we've been covering in
this hour together that you're not going
to let anybody else stop you on reaching
those worthwhile goals and you're
certainly not going to stop yourself but
let me say this what you get by reaching
your goals is not nearly as important as
what you will become by reaching the
goal that many people said you would not
make when you started out I close with
this by these ideas follow these
suggestions adopt these procedures as
your very own follow them right through
to completion and I'll definitely see
you and yes I really do mean
you at the
top thank you
very to watch the legendary Earl
Nightingale Strangest Secret check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I'd like to tell you
about The Strangest Secret in the world
not long ago Albert schwitzer the Great
doctor and Nobel Prize winner was being
interviewed in London and a reporter
asked him doctor what's wrong with men
today